Earlier, we discussed some innovative approaches to physician charting.
Now that we have discussed semantic interoperability,
you can better appreciate the approach to
EHR documentation that Applicadia has developed.
Richard Esmond, the company's chief technical
officer and co-chair of the CIMI work group,
has prepared a short video for this course.
In it, you will see what he calls a graph
that is always focused around a clinical concept node
and presents the relationships it has to any other concept nodes known to the platform.
The node at the focus could be from SNOMED, ICD,
LOINC or RxNorm, some of the health data standards,
we will discuss in the next lesson.
It also might be a synthetic knowledge element that the company has parsed
or analytically computed and then attached to that node through a relationship.
Finally, a small but growing number of nodes are derived
from the clinical knowledge artifacts in CIMI models.
The video, though short,
is very rich conceptually and illustrates a number of interesting possibilities.
The use of voice recognition for medical documentation.
The use of an NLP to properly place voice narration into the traditional sections of
a medical note and even the proper body system area of the review of systems,
a key part of a medical note.
Automatic encoding of free text notes into
complex data standards such as SNOMED and ICD-10.
The further use of NLP to properly map voice narrative to the clinical concept graphs,
thus, creating a basis for semantic interoperability.
The use of a concept graph to guide the physician to properly
code into the very clinically detailed ICD-10 system.
The discussion of the history of present illness part of the note
concerning the patient's knee problem, illustrates this.
Similarly, this use of a concept graph could help the physician properly report
quality metrics or to remind them to provide
important but missing clinical details for a concept they've identified.
I urge you to study the video carefully using this list of capabilities.